I don't know I think homophobia can
actually be kind of dangerous you know a
friend of mine he's kind of a tough guy
he went skydiving recently he's like
yeah I'm not strapping some guy in my
back that's super gay
now he's dead
I don't know homophobia I'm not gay I do
like the ladies big fan of the old labia
yeah yeah yeah uh which is weird because
when I was a kid I hated girls when I
was like six years old I thought girls
were gross thought they were dumb you
know you're allowed to hate girls as a
kid but that's really the only group a
kid's allowed to hate if I was a
six-year-old that hated
Puerto Ricans
that would be weird you know if I was
like hey Mom I hate Puerto Rican she
would never say oh you'll like them one
day
you don't like them a lot you guys are a
fun group uh some crowds get so offended
by these dumb jokes you know I had a guy
come up to me after a show once he goes
hey buddy I'm gay and Puerto Rican all
right
I don't appreciate those jokes you know
how hard my life is I was like whoa take
it easy how hard your life is dude you
have the most parades